this is the best day america could have
hoped for
we've had four years of trump we know
what
the rest of the world thinks about us
now we can finally
finally begin to be great again and take
our place in the world
so the rest of the world can now look up
to us again like a dictator
what about donald trump saying this
isn't over oh it's over baby
it's over it was over on tuesday all the
votes just hadn't been counted
what's your name martine martine francis
and i'm actually from the uk
natural born citizen and proud again to
be an american
for the last four years i hadn't been
proud now
i'm ejubilated i'm proud to be an
american again
a biden fan what do you what do you make
of where we are
that's what this was about it was it
wasn't blue or red it's more of a purple
thing
a native northern virginian divisiveness
you know
house divided cannot stand and uh i'll
just say that
it's good to see everyone's out here
peacefully and it's time for america to
get back to
being who we are yeah they are
peacefully and that is good to see
is it good to see donald trump stating
that this is not over by a long shot
it is over and like he said he says not
yeah but he's not the people he's not
the electoral college he's not the state
it's the united states of america it's
not the prison united states of america
ruling is one it's just interesting that
he's playing golf
he's probably stuck in the sand trap and
this is all going on so
here's to america you're on the side of
victory as things stand right now
although that may change i suppose will
it change
have no merit the lawsuits have no merit
read the lawsuits there's no evidence
they're producing frivolous lawsuits to
waste american money
and time joe biden has won he has a
mandate he's going to have more
electoral votes
than trump had when he was elected in
2016. trump pack your
get out because you're done what does a
biden victory mean for your country
bringing my country together i have been
so
every day waking up with the stress of
having donald trump
uh alienate one group or the other we're
not allowed we
i travel extensively there's nowhere in
the universe like where i'm allowed
because of how this cova virus has been
handled by trump
it's ridiculous it's embarrassing and
this brings back
the the the reputation we have the paris
mayor
tweeted welcome back america and i say
to you welcome back america we're back
okay and very briefly madame tell me
your your thoughts just in a sentence
i'm just
happy that uh the exhaustion will be
over
the stress of of what every day was
going to bring with him
and the the slurs and the misogyny i'm
happy it's over